people that have a near-death experience
that is in general the most amazing
influential experience of their life
let's talk about sacred to them yeah
okay so so that's interesting so people
say it's sacred to them you know um what
are some kind yeah what are some of the
things if people go there they're on
death's doorstep and they get to come
back you know nobody was home they
knocked they got some information maybe
you know uh but what is some of the
things that they what what do we have
you learned anything about the afterlife
I guess or that that next step have you
learned anything about that or do you
feel like you've learned anything
absolutely I am extremely interested in
that after years of doing research and
being aware that they were remarkably
consistently describing unearthly you
know Heavenly Realms obviously as a
researcher I'm danged interested in that
so in our most recent version of the
survey we've got a lot of questions
where I try to drill down on that try to
understand more about that that
remarkably consistent perspective on
what lies Beyond death's door and that's
where Theo it gets dang interesting one
thing we're okay talk interesting here
so what's it like okay you know here it
first of all you have to understand it's
radically different from that physical
Earthly like that we know it's nothing
like a separate geographically independ
we only have five senses dude yeah oh
yeah you how manyan senses you get
probably when you're done here well more
you know there's yeah 12 senses I bet
okay about all the other senses you
could have the more the merrier I know
but regarding what I'm consistently
seeing based on survey questions and and
spontaneous comments that they have the
afterlife again completely non-physical
emotions non-physical
communication uh they typically have a
greatly accelerated Consciousness they
often have amazingly what they call
Universal knowledge it's a sense of
knowing everything it's a bigger picture
of knowledge far more than they could
have known in their Earthly life the one
thing you said that was interesting was
being able to make a decision maybe to
come or to go so there's some like it's
almost like do you want to stay do you
want to try this new thing you know uh
that's interesting what else you know
what it's interesting what's interesting
Theo is that when they're in that realm
when they're in that beautiful unearthly
realm feeling love and peace beyond
anything the new on their Earthly life
that's not unfamiliar they often say
this is a strong sense of their real
home like that and not their Earthly
life and that's one reason they want to
stay there they know their friends
family and loved ones that they leave
behind are going to be okay that they
too will be in that realm when their
time comes it's that feeling you get to
when you hug somebody that you love I
think I like that I like that a lot and
exactly that feeling it's almost it's
not even about the you're happy that
it's them you know but it's really not
even for there's a little bit of
sometimes in a moment in a hug where
it's not even about them it's just about
this like other little space that gets
created kind of that just feels uh
absolutely welcoming you know I'm
talking about kind of yeah I love
talking about love so we'll focus on
that but yeah when you've got a hug and
you've got that intense sense of love
you can understand in personal
experience the words in the dictionary
that it's like a connection like a unity
and you often can feel that and because
the love described in near-death
experience is one of the most common
words you see that the in the afterlife
described and near-death experiences one
of the most consistent themes amazingly
is they do feel that that and they use a
stronger word the connection much more
commonly saying it's a Unity it's a
Oneness of of us and of everyone it's
sort of like the super if you will Ultra
love is what our destiny is going to be
in the afterlife oh yeah for example we
had from Canada we had a car bad car
accident and a gentleman was driving
with his fiance iance boom Carr fell
asleep and hit a tree both him and his
fiance had that out of- Body Experience
holding hands I mean their fiance rose
up and then they were able to see this
unearthly beautiful realm in the
distance there were four beings that
came up to them two of them went to her
two of them went to him and they
separated their holding hands they felt
so much peace and love they described he
wanted to say no but but felt so
compelling compellingly that's why it
was remarkable that he felt so much
peace and love that he didn't want to
resist it and so he watched the two
beings carry his fiance toward this
beautiful unearthly realm in the
distance the other two beings gently
lowered him back down to the car from
way above the car he saw the front end
on fire and then he went back into his
body and he felt when he return to
Consciousness his fiance leaning on his
shoulder as she was when he had the
accident and he knew immediately fiance
was dead she was an empty shell and that
he had left her with those beings above
that's a shared near-death experience
and very dramatic shared near-death
experiences are that's unbelievable I
mean out of 4,000 you know it have maybe
about 20 that's how rare they are and
yet they're so dramatic in terms of
providing evidence that for those that
permanently irreversibly die their
Consciousness continues to live and will
eventually be reunited what have you
garnered from uh speaking with people
who have been close to the afterlife and
um what have you garnered from that oh
that's that's where my research gets
amazingly interesting what I'm seeing is
well Theo it's a basic scientific
principle that what's real is
consistently observed and that's where
it's exciting when you look at the
afterlife in near-death experiences
because what's described now times
thousands is so amazingly consistent I
mean it's a beautiful unearthly realm
that strong sense of peace and love but
off the scale beyond anything they knew
in their Earthly life um the encounters
with deceased loved ones interactions by
the way deceased pets are often
described in near-death experiences and
these are again joyous you know for
animal lovers out there tremendously
good news from near-death experiences I
mean hey Theo you name it dogs cats
birds horses I've seen not rats we be
pet well I mean I haven't heard that but
you know certainly pets are are not it's
not at all unusual and like other
deceased humans that they knew these are
joyous reunions and you know sort of
back to that sharing like they did on
Earth only here they are in the
afterlife so so do they see that they
see these people in the afterlife what
do people say they physically see they
see their father cousin or grandparent
or something they see them in the way
that they saw them on Earth um not NE is
there any information about that oh lot
like how do people see people when they
when they have a near-death experience
how do former humans that they knew or
humans that they knew on Earth that are
now gone how do they see them in uh in
the ndes right they're essentially
always picture perfect health even if
they died of an advanced age or a
disfiguring debilitating accident or
injury when they're encountered in the
afterlife they're essentially always
absolutely picture perfect health
interestingly if someone died in an
extremely advanced stage they may appear
even decades younger yes and if they
died in very early childhood amazingly
they may appear in older childhood
really and so it seems to be that kind
of interplay usually yeah usually they
look pretty much you know and they can
tell and another interesting thing you
almost never have people say Mary is
that you it's it's an immediate and
intense deep understanding that this is
their beloved they can share from issue
you know what they had and they
experienced in their past life um
there's a predisposition for genetic
relatives but you can be anything
obviously spouses or uh you know pretty
much it friends uh loved people so it it
again a beautiful beautiful part of
near-death experiences where you have
that joyous reunion and in fact even if
the Earthly life was strained in the
afterlife it's that's not an issue
anymore there's joyous sharing there can
be sort of like the analogous of of
interaction touch you can't really touch
you're non physical but there's
certainly a lot of that kind of very
close sharing an interaction a very
beautiful very touching part of
near-death experience what motivates you
to care about this I am fascinated by
near-death experiences even after 25
years and 4,000 near-death experi in
Bush Gardens yeah I have oh yeah that's
awesome too isn't that's that's true but
I love all that kind of stuff it's fun
well near death experiences to me it it
continues to remind me that there's an
afterlife a wonderful afterlife and
that's for all of us I'm a physician
that treats patients with cancer these
are my patients that have
life-threatening events and I'm involved
with them every day what I know about
near-death experience has helped me to
help them in their Journey with their
battle with cancer in a way with more
courage more confidence that even if we
ultimately don't cure them that in the
end they're going to have a wonderful
afterlife and as I've told them you're
going to be in a much better place than
those left on our Earthly life so I
think that's really uh you know
certainly something to look forward to I
hope I believe that too because even
just living is so like that's what I
always say when people are like I don't
believe in an
afterlife um I'm like all right you know
like first of all
what like
okay you know because here's why my
biggest proof is that we lived at all
yeah that's my like at least believe in
reincarnation because we already lived
yeah how you you then why then don't
even believe you're here then if you're
not even going to believe it's possible
that's that's ridiculous like I'm doing
this right now you're going to tell me
and I came out of nothing I don't know
where I was you know I got some vague
ideas and you know I'll sketch some
stuff every now and then but I don't
have any real information but to think
this couldn't happen again to me seems
asinine it because you you have proof
like you're living in proof like it'd be
different if you weren't but you're
freaking living in proof that you that
existence from nothing is possible now I
know you came from people when you came
from sex but they eventually we don't
know where they came from MH you know
yeah and we don't know where life came
from that's the thing sure no and
absolutely that's sorry to yell at you
or anything no this is great hey Theo
this is what I find among other things
very inspiring about near-death
experiences I mean here over and over is
very powerful evidence that we do have a
life after death our Consciousness goes
on we're not really going both for us
our friends our family our loved ones
when we have that final end of our
Earthly physical life there's a much
bigger picture a much we continuation of
Consciousness uh Eternal and infinite as
best I can tell from near-death
experiences and that's exciting
I mean whenever Earthly life gets Miser
difficult we've all been there all of us
and you always have that that thought in
the back of your mind from near-death
experiences wow here is the evidence
powerful evidence that we go
on